qui dit tu as perdu tes parents
bienvenue tu es ma nièce je vais faire
mon possible pour que tu te sentes chez
toi ici je voudrais qu'il soit encore là
avec moi
je sais pas du tout comment je vais
gérer ça je sais même pas m'occuper de
mes plantes
je travaille sur un projet très
important tu veux le voir oui
depuis toute petite je rêve d'un jouet
parfait capable d'aider les enfants à se
sentir moins seul ou moins triste je te
présente mes gamins salut Megane je
m'appelle Kelly
[Musique]
ravi de te rencontrer Teddy tu veux être
mon ami
d'accord
ta mission est de protéger keidi au
mieux de tout dommage physique et
émotionnel
c'est une poupée modèle 3 génératif
Android on l'appelle Mégane et c'est toi
qui l'a fabriqué j'adore
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est comme si elle faisait
partie de la famille elle pourrait
développer des liens émotionnels qui
risquent d'être trop difficile à briser
je n'ai pas vu qu'il dit aux yeux
heureuse depuis la mort de ses parents
finit ton assiette qui a dit des études
montrer que si on force un enfant à
manger des légumes il aura moins envie
d'en manger une fois devenu adulte oui
les experts
[Musique]
je veux l'entendre parler
de courir
[Musique]
mes gammes c'est toi qui a poussé
Brandon sur la route je ne laisserai
rien te faire souffrir
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui te prend
ne t'inquiète pas qui
je ne laisserai rien te faire souffrir
[Musique]
plus jamais